our next presentation is from the other
of our missing bodies who said I can't
miss this show so what we have is Sean
Cole who is a professor at the Harvard
Business School and a member of the
poverty action lab at MIT and here he
will be talking on the value of advice
evidence from a mobile phone-based
agricultural advice service in India so
here we go
hi I'm Sean coal from the Harvard
Business School and it's a real pleasure
to have the opportunity to talk to you
about my research I'm really sorry that
I can't be here today unfortunately Matt
Prior travel plans preclude a personal
appearance so I'm here to talk about a
paper called the value of agricultural
advice evidence from agricultural
production practices this is joint work
with a PhD student of mine neelesh
fernando and the motivating question
behind this paper is that there's
dramatic variation in the level of
agricultural productivity around the
world from country to country or even
within region some states experience
higher levels of productivity than
others or even within the state some
farmers very close to each other have
quite different levels of agricultural
productivity a lot of research is
focused on the role of inputs but in
this paper we take a different tack
which is can management practices help
explain the variations productivity and
in particular can a mobile phone-based
agricultural advice service improve
agricultural practices and agricultural
productivity and so the traditional way
of reaching farmers is through training
and visit style Agricultural Extension
this has some problems farmers are
spatially quite spread out often and so
it's expensive to travel to reach them
sometimes it's impossible because
they've left the village to live in huts
very close to their field the there's a
spatial aspect of giving advice farmers
might need information about a
particular pest attack during the season
and it's hard to know before the season
begins when you give the extension what
types of pests might might come or what
other things might come up so what we
study is an agricultural advice service
called a hora Basel 0 which was
delivered by developed by a computer
science tests from Stanford and Berkeley
and the coding behind it isn't that
complicated but what they focused on was
a human machine interaction and how you
can bring a platform that's very similar
to the Internet to farmers with very low
levels of literacy and very low levels
of technological sophistication so what
it is is it a voice based service that
does two primary things first it
provides a push call every week about
five minutes long that provides relevant
timely targeted agricultural information
so if certain type of pests
been spotted in the vicinity the bush
call my alert farmers to look out for
that and provide them guidance with what
type of pesticide might be useful in
dealing with the pest the second key
features that has a question-and-answer
service so if a farmer has a specific
question they can call him to the
service record that question our
agronomist will then listen to the
question record an answer the answer
gets pushed back to the farmer and the
farmer gets customized advice on demand
and so what we found in this study was
that k-cup was quite high so our study
sample was 1200 randomly selected
farmers in gujarat an in-state in the
north of India to be in our sample you
had to grow cotton and you had to have a
mobile phone about ninety percent of the
farmers who grow cotton in our area
already had mobile phones so that wasn't
much of a constraint the average age is
46 years old they have four years of
education we divide them into a group
that gets the agricultural advice
information service by phone as well as
a traditional control group so the first
thing first striking finding we found
was that use of the services very high
sixty-three percent of the treatment
population called in to ask a question
about their own agricultural experiences
and in total fifty-four percent of the
push content that we delivered by mobile
phone was listened to so the average
farmer and our treatment got about a
hundred and twenty minutes of
agricultural advice builder to them over
the phone over a two-year period and you
know the first test you want to pass is
that farmers report that your service is
a useful source of information so we
asked farmers at a baseline in a bid
line and an end line now where do you go
for information about pesticides about
seeds etc etc and the farmers the
treatment group are significantly more
likely to report our mobile phones as a
useful sources their primary source of
information for cotton pesticides and
fertilizers seeds we pesticides cue and
pesticides best identification and
whether importantly for us they weren't
more likely to report cell phones as a
source for price information we didn't
offer price information in the service
of course where the rubber hits the road
is whether you can actually affect
agricultural practices
to facilitate analysis we aggregated
behaviors in each specific category up
to a single index so for example we
found that the information service
improve common pest management practices
cotton fertilizer practices and common
sewing and input practices relative to
the control group these effects were
statistically significant at the five
percent level in addition and much more
excitement the service seemed to have
benefited farmers in terms of yield so
we had three groups in the study we had
the control group we had a group that
was the entire treatment group and then
we studied a specific subgroup to whom
we sent regular reminders to use the
service these reminders induced
additional usage of the service what we
found was that among those who receive
the reminders use the service this group
experienced 60 kilograms per acre higher
cotton yields that's off a base of about
six hundred and ninety acres so that's
about a ten percent increase in hot
meals similarly both the entire group
and the subsample that receive reminders
experience significant increases about
thirty three percent in their cumin
yields taken together the value of this
output would exceed the cost of
providing the service although for the
sake of full transparency I'll note that
our estimate of log agricultural profits
while positive at about sixteen percent
is not statistically significant one
interesting thing about information is
that in contrast to fertilizer or seeds
is quite easily spread from farmer to
farmer we actually designed our study to
measure whether pure affects whether
this information affected peers before
we rolled out the service we asked each
farmer who their primary agricultural
contacts were then we could compare
people whose friends were randomly
assigned to the treatment group to
instead assigned to the control group
what we found was striking about
nineteen percent of the people whose
peers were assigned to the treatment
group reported that an NGO with the name
of our service was a primary sources of
information for them we also found that
people whose peers were assigned to the
treatment group planted more cumin and
reported lower loss of
due to cotton pests finally we examined
whether the service might work in a
market context by measuring willingness
to pay to measure willingness to pay we
went to each farmer after the study was
over two years after the service and
said we're just about to discontinue
this free service but if you'd like to
continue for an additional six months
you may do so by paying us a hundred
rupees right now and what we did is we
randomly varied the price at which are
jus farmers to measure the demand curve
what we found is that low price is very
high fraction of farmers wanted the
service up to ninety percent the price
of one dollar once you increase the
price to something much higher say eight
or ten dollars for a six-month period
demand dropped down to about eight
percent this provides us some hope that
the surface may be commercially viable
but it seems like we still have a long
way to go so in conclusion I'd like to
leave you with this demand for
information was very hard among a sample
of mostly illiterate farmers seventy
percent of the farmers called in to ask
a question we found very high levels of
reported trust in the cell phone
information and we affected agricultural
practices agricultural yields and we
seem to have had significant spill overs
so this suggests that any rollout
offered by a government or an NGO would
benefit not just the people who receive
the service but their peers thank you
very much